eccoci qui benvenuti in un nuovo
terrificante video come vi avevo
promesso oggi vi svelerò come
trasformati in altre mie colleghe
davvero cattive truccatissima dagli
zigomi appuntiti scheletrica dai gesti
plateali attorniata dal pesante fetore
della sigaretta che fuma tramite un
lungo bucchino rosso de chi sto parlando
se non della crudele crudelia demon dopo
aver applicato il fondotinta il
correttore sopra le sopracciglia che per
questo make up non ci serviranno
applichiamo un ombretto azzurro
metallizzato sulla palpebra fissa e
sulla palpebra mobile fino quasi ad
arrivare le sopracciglia poi stendiamo
la eyeliner allungandolo bene lungo
l'angolo esterno dell'occhio
partendo proprio dall'angolo esterno
disegniamo sempre con liner una sorta di
ovale che vada a delimitare tutto
l'occhio compresa la parte inferiore
[Musica]
applichiamo il mascara e dopo aver
truccato anche l'altro occhio passiamo
le sopracciglia con una matita marrone
vi consiglio di disegnare prima dei
puntini per rendere più semplice in
tutto le sopracciglia andranno a
occupare praticamente tutta la fronte e
ovviamente devono essere super super
arcuate una volta disegnato e con la
matita e andiamo a ripassare con liner
nero
applichiamo le ciglia finte
e passiamo al con touring partiamo dal
naso con una matita marrone
tracciamo una linea che partendo
dall'attaccatura delle nostre
sopracciglia quelle vere arrivi fino a
metà naso
con lei liner nero andiamo a ingrandire
le nostre narici per accentuarle per
creare l'effetto naso da maiale
[Musica]
proseguiamo con il con touring e andiamo
ad accentuare gli zigomi sfumando il
tutto
[Musica]
passiamo alle labbra che andremo a
delineare con una matita rossa cercando
di andare oltre il nostro contorno
labbra
[Musica]
stendiamo poi la tinta labbra rosso
fuoco e via crudelia è pronta
[Musica]
[Applauso]
così
per quanto riguarda la utt crudelia io
ho utilizzato un tubino bianco e nero se
ce l'avete anche solo nero fa benissimo
un paio di guanti rossi una pelliccetta
maculato bianca io per esempio l'ho
comprata online perché non ce l'avevo a
casa la parrucca bianca e nera e se
volete con tocco di stile in più il
bocchino se avete dei cuccioli vi
consiglio di chiuderli in casa perché
crudelia de mon potrebbe essere i
paraggi per avere un paio di gambe
ariel era disposto a qualsiasi cosa
decise quindi di stringere un patto con
la più temuta è cattiva strega degli
abissi sto parlato di ursula inizierai
dicendo che questo è il travestimento
più complicato di tutti dopo essermi
pitturata décolleté braccia mani collo
steso l'acqua color viola anche sul viso
tralasciando la zona del contorno occhi
o coperto le sopracciglia con il
correttore che poi sono andata a
tamponare delicatamente con la spugnetta
a questo punto disegnato da super
palpebra d urso la e sono andata a
riempirla con un ombretto in crema
azzurro
ho applicato liner nero sulla rima
ciliare inferiore e ho steso l'ombretto
azzurro anche sotto l'occhio
matita bianca all'interno dell'occhio e
con un pennellino ho iniziato a sfumare
bene il tutto
ho applicato lai liner anche sulla rima
ciliare superiore allungandolo bene
verso l'angolo esterno dell'occhio ho
disegnato delle soap risse e
sopracciglia super arcuate sono andata a
riempire lo spazio tra le sopracciglia
gli occhi con un ombretto grigio
[Musica]
ho applicato un ombretto super shimmer
azzurro sulla palpebra fissa e sulla
palpebra mobile per rendere l'occhio più
tridimensionale un po di mascara e
soprattutto le mie amate ciglia finte
[Musica]
a questo punto l'acqua color
asciugandosi era assolutamente da
sistemare
ci ha pensato quindi e doc con un
pennellino andato pazientemente a
ritoccare tutto il viso
infine ho applicato la tinta labbra
rossa sulle labbra e dopo aver disegnato
il super neo di ursula la mia urso la ha
preso vita
[Musica]
il make up è stato difficilissimo da
realizzare loutit invece è stato
veramente facile infatti come potete
vedere indosso un semplice tubino nero
che trovate tutti nel vostro armadio e
una parrucca bianca
se ad halloween vi travestì rete da
ursula beh datevi una bella lavata prima
di ficcarmi nel letto spero che anche
questi travestimenti vi siano piaciuti
fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto
da cosa vi travestì rete ad halloween
spero vivamente che prendiate
ispirazioni danny ai travestimenti top
se non avete ancora fatto vi ricordo di
iscrivervi al canale e di cliccare sulla
campanella che trovate vicino al tasso
d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre sempre
aggiornati su tutti miei video e
soprattutto per essere i primi a
commentare
ricordatevi di seguirmi su tutti gli
altri social instagram facebook e tic
toc
non vi resta che salutarvi e augurarvi
buon halloween
adoro
[Musica]